uh
put your thinking caps on folks i'm
going to blow your mind hey everyone i'm
abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
we'll be chatting about the potential
danger of intermittent fasting on
women's hormones but first let me tell
you about my sponsor iherb so i know
from my sibo saga that trying to track
down all the right supplements in one
place can feel like a full-time job in
itself so iherb makes this process so
much easier with over 30 000 products
including supplements sports nutrition
beauty bath grocery baby and pets i also
love that you can check the products
expiration date before you buy you can
make sure that you get the lifespan that
you need plus they have their own
in-house line that's being third-party
tested which is key and you get a 90-day
money-back guarantee and if you have any
questions about products or supplements
they have a support line open five days
a week in 10 different languages so it
makes finding the right product so much
easier and if you use supplements
regularly like i do they have a members
rewards program that lets you cash out
for every hundred dollars in credits
that you earn so you can either review
products that you bought answer
questions from customers or refer
friends or family so in my hall i got
the pez science vegan protein which i
definitely wanted to try myself because
i do love their whey protein i got
california gold prebiotic fiber which is
key for regularity and my sibo protocol
i got some melatonin which i use nightly
for sleep i got nails ultra omega-3s
which is key for brain and heart health
and i got california gold's vitamin d3
for bones and my immune system these are
some of the core products that i buy
regularly so i'm just so happy that i
can find them all in one place so if you
want to check this out yourself you can
use my promo code abby to get 20 off of
your order as always feel free to pause
the screen or look at the description
including a big trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating we will be
discussing calorie deficits and weight
loss so as always feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and if you are new here don't
forget to subscribe to the channel ring
that bell and follow me on instagram and
tick tock abby's kitchen if you missed
my overview of the literature on
intermittent fasting for weight loss you
can check that video out right here but
this is a huge topic that i cannot
possibly unpack in its entirety in one
video so today we're going to
specifically address the impact of
fasting on women's hormones and answer
the age-old question is this diet
even safe and i'm going to warn you now
this is a more high level concept so
put your thinking caps on now also when
i'm speaking to the safety of this diet
i'm going to for a moment put aside the
psychological or emotional or mental
risks or dangers associated with dieting
i'm going to assume for the purposes of
this video that dieting or in this case
intermittent fasting as a diet is
psychologically appropriate for you so
my discussion of the safety profile is
speaking specifically to the physical
safety or the risk for hormonal health
first a quick little recap on
intermittent fasting so while results
vary person to person the literature
suggests that interim fasting can result
in weight loss across the lifespan so we
have studies ranging from premenopausal
to postmenopausal women and of course
also men however there's nothing magical
about fasting for weight loss compared
to other diets in fact research suggests
that it's really no more effective than
classic continuous caloric restriction
ultimately when we skip a meal we're
just kind of bad at making up for those
calories in full but is it a less safe
diet for women than counting calories or
points well if you're a person who
menstruates you'll know and agree that
we really don't want to mess with normal
hormonal function honestly hormones
cause enough trouble on a good day no
one wants to poke that bear
so is intermittent fasting off the table
for us gals let's take a look at the
facts i spoke with my colleague eric
williamson over at unlocked fitness and
nutrition who expertly explained the
link between intermittent fasting and
hormonal imbalance in his facebook
intermittent fasting video series now
while the premise of intermittent
fasting is to simply shorten your eating
window it generally results in two main
side effects that have implications for
body weight and hormones that is number
one we end up just eating fewer calories
overall and number two we end up eating
fewer meals or snacks in the day so as
we already established it's actually
side effect number one that is
responsible for weight loss and i'm
gonna explain the implications for
number two the number of meals in a
minute
number two but first let's discuss the
concept of energy availability and how
it relates to diets like intermittent
fasting so most people when they talk
about weight loss they talk about energy
balance which is just basically calories
in minus calories out but this doesn't
account for metabolic changes that act
on real-time changes in energy intake
and expenditure so energy availability
also focuses on energy requirements
breaking them into two main components
energy for exercise and movement and
energy for health and vitality when
there is low energy availability your
body can start to down regulate
functions for your health to deal with
the deficit some of which are in my
books kind of essential
perhaps you're right so energy
availability can be calculated across
the day but it can also be calculated
down to each hour of the day so we often
discuss this in the literature as within
day energy balance so to recap this is
the simplified energy balance equation
and this is the within day energy
balance equation so as a simplified
example that my colleague eric gave me
let's say someone eats 400 calories at
12 o'clock
and then burns through 700 calories by 3
o'clock
this means
at 3 o'clock they would be in a negative
energy balance by about 300 calories and
have low energy availability now what we
know is that for women more hours of the
day spent in an energy availability
below minus 300 calories is associated
with menstrual dysfunction and hormonal
irregularities so if we put this into
layman's terms this is the critical
threshold where on average a diet can
become potentially hormonally unsafe for
the average female now i want to
reiterate that i'm not saying that a 300
calorie daily deficit is necessarily
dangerous it might be but that's a
different term than the 300 calorie
within day energy deficiency that i'm
actually referring to i know it's
complicated and this is not something
that we can easily calculate on
myfitnesspal so like don't even try
but this is why having a skilled
dietitian on board is really
really key it's also important to flag
that we can all handle dipping below the
critical threshold occasionally because
maybe we got busy at work we skipped a
meal or maybe because we feel so sick
that we can't eat for an extra few hours
one day our bodies can recover from that
kind of occasional blip but hormonal
problems really arise when we have
chronically low energy availability in
the day very very dangerous now it's
important to note that the female
reproductive system is very sensitive to
energy imbalances and losing too much
weight or being underweight has
absolutely been shown to negatively
impact fertility so we've talked about
hypothalamic amenorrhea in my video
right here but this is the most severe
form of menstrual disturbances
associated with infertility and is also
commonly associated with dieting and
disordered eating basically what happens
is that chronic low energy availability
can disrupt gonadotropin releasing
hormone which then has a domino effect
on estrogen and progesterone potentially
halting reproduction so research
suggests that gonadotropin releasing
hormone levels actually dropped by about
20 to 30 within just two to three days
of calorie deprivation so this actually
can happen quite fast we also know that
prolonged fasting periods of around 72
hours can cause an endocrine response
similar to that seen in hypothalamic
amenorrhea and one of the reasons for
this seems to be linked to our satiety
hormone leptin so leptin is not only
important for regulating our appetite
but it is key for reproduction through
its relationship with lh release so in
the research we see that low levels of
leptin are associated with reduced
fertility and increased rates of
miscarriage bottom line here folks and
that's the bottom line
we want to maintain healthy levels of
leptin through adequate body fat and
adequate body weight because that's
imperative if a healthy pregnancy is the
eventual goal now some of you might say
i don't want kids so why should you care
about not having a cycle well without
adequate estrogen levels to sustain a
period and ovulation and therefore a
pregnancy we also increase our risk of
low bone density suppressed bone
strength and risk of fractures one study
found that it took as little as five
days of not eating enough to affect our
bones and if you continue to overeat
this can lead to irreversible reductions
in bone mineral density so not to be a
total debbie downer but if you're over
the age of 30 or even 25 it's all kind
of downhill from here in the bone
department
there are no more opportunities to bank
more bone later on
yes well that can sometimes happen so
again this is why it's critical to catch
and reverse this hormonal down
regulation super early on in life okay
and then what about those of you who
don't want kids don't care about your
bone health for some reason or maybe
don't have female hormones to contend
with at all maybe you just want to lose
weight and intermittent fasting works
for you well
here's the
inconvenient truth spending a lot of
time under this critical threshold is
associated with lower than expected rmr
or resting metabolic rates in
non-menstruating folks and in severe
cases we see completely devastating
effects on metabolic hormones so things
like our satiety hormone leptin tanks
our stress hormone cortisol and our
hunger hormone ghrelin increases and our
thyroid hormones get all out of whack
essentially our metabolism slows down in
an effort to conserve energy to just
keep us alive meanwhile with a
suppressed resting metabolic rate and a
raging appetite we burn fewer calories
at rest and we want to eat all the
things so despite our best efforts
weight loss slows and we can actually
put weight on in fact some research
suggests that our rmr can actually drop
as much as 400 fewer calories when we're
chronically eating which means you're
burning 400 fewer calories less every
day so spending time under the critical
threshold not only sucks for morale if
weight loss is your goal but it also can
have the complete opposite effect as
your goal so does this mean that you
cannot eat in a caloric deficit and try
to lose weight without risking hormonal
imbalance well the key here folks is to
avoid spending a lot of time below your
critical threshold so to recap in normal
words hormonal disturbance is not only
about the daily caloric deficit we
calculate on like a stupid online app
but it's also to do with a much more
complicated calculation of how much time
you're spending in a sub-optimal state
of energy availability every day where
your body doesn't have enough calories
on board in that hour to maintain health
and vitality so yes a modest deficit and
weight loss pace is important here but
it's not just about total calories
because you can actually dip below the
critical threshold without a calorie
deficit at all it's about how often and
for how long your tank is on empty each
day aka the within day energy deficiency
and this is where the unique danger of
intermittent fasting comes into play
intermittent fasting often encourages
you to go long stretches of time without
eating sometimes during which you're
exercising and expending a lot of energy
if you're concerned about happy hormones
which i think we all should be my
colleague eric suggests that it's often
safer to eat a few smaller meals spaced
out throughout the day rather than
relying on one or two large meals later
on in the day which ironically
is kind of what many intermittent
fasting regimens prescribe essentially
what you want to do is give your body
small bursts of energy but each time it
starts reaching that critical threshold
it's
lifted up enough for you to make it to
your next meal and by doing this you'll
keep your energy levels above the
critical threshold while still
maintaining a safe and modest caloric
deficit so does that mean all
intermittent fasting regimens are unsafe
for women here's the thing obviously
it's impossible to make a blanket
statement that any one way of eating is
going to be safe or healthy for 50 of
the population and i'm not even going to
get into the mental or emotional or
psychological risks or dangers of
dieting period that's a whole other
conversation and i'm going to assume for
the purposes of this video that weight
loss is deemed appropriate but some
methods of fasting will likely be more
or less
physically risky for the masses for
example whole day and alternate day
fasting will probably result in eating
way too few calories and more time being
spent under the critical threshold every
day and this is bad news bears in
general but specifically for women who
are already relatively lean exercise a
lot or who are trying to conceive now or
in the future so when i asked eric if
there was a universally safe
intermittent fasting protocol for women
of course his response was it's very
difficult to answer and of course it is
i mean humans are all unique so for eric
this really depends on how much someone
eats when they eat how many feedings
they have in the day when they exercise
and how much and whether their daily
total is in an energy balance or a
significant deficit this is complicated
and also really points to why it's ideal
to have a dietitian on board to help so
in an effort to clarify again bottom
line generally speaking eric says that
most women should stick to no more than
a 12 to 16 hour fast max and where your
safe number lies will depend on a few
factors if you're having fewer meals in
the day if you're in a caloric deficit
aka trying to lose weight if you're
exercising heavily or if the majority of
your calories are happening at the end
of the day you'll want to limit your
time in that fast to the more modest 12
hours to be safe in conclusion chronic
under eating can lead to a variety of
hormonal disturbances that can cause a
host of health problems down the line
intermittent fasting will not
necessarily put you under the critical
threshold or put you at risk of hormonal
damage but depending on when what and
how much you eat the risk is higher than
if you were to eat meals spaced more
evenly throughout the day weight loss
without reproductive or hormonal damage
is of course possible but a less is
better approach will always risk more
harm so as always definitely reach out
to a registered dietitian who
specializes in weight loss and hormonal
health because this is far more
complicated than what any influencer
online suggests i mean if the complexity
of this video didn't illustrate that i'm
not sure what will and on that note that
is all that i have for you guys today if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on what or who you'd like to see me
discuss next subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]